what up it's your neighborhood pushing
one half of the clips re-upgame forever
newest i need a good music you checking
out bootleg kev on bootleg
calm yeah
what up what up we live at the magic
convention right now we're in the play
closed booth right now that's what we
got right now yeah man why don't you
tell us how the the progression of the
brand has been crazy from when it first
started yeah your guys's booth is one of
the biggest ones here yeah um what's
next for the brand man i mean man it's
just all about growth honestly we've
been in it for um one or four years now
yeah so i mean that within itself is an
accomplishment to me i mean coming from
where i'm from yeah and just you know
just having nothing more than just a
passion for you know streetwear and just
the fashion so we here you know it
started from my idea and it's grown into
four years worth of
you know uh a good movement right right
you guys have always like kind of been
been uh trailblazers with fashion you're
out with the the bait rappers first yes
sir yes yes sir yeah you know we um
we uh luckily you know just being
embraced by um nego and and just being
uh having uh you know being on star trek
and pharrell was like really fashion
forward yeah as well so like it helped
out yeah so just being under you know
his tutelage most definitely now now the
music game um you drop fear of god put
out a bunch of videos with it yeah um
you just dropped the amen record with uh
jeezy and kanye yeah crazy record um
fear god too that's coming out that's
gonna be in stores right yeah i think
this is gonna be in stores digitally i'm
not even sure it's coming out on decon
yeah okay decon yeah decons i'm gonna
distribute it and um you know basically
it's um you know some of the
the originals from the old fairy god and
and new joints like you know you've been
mentioning that you just mentioned um
i mean me personally i'd just be putting
the records out so you know what you get
is what you're going to get because as
soon as i do them you usually get them
so
um
so from the tyler to the amen
to the uh there's no real order of
operation we're just throwing it out um
what what is because
i know you what made you want to put
that out through decon and like put it
out i mean as opposed to the first take
that was out for free um well you know
initially um i i'm 100
about just
the whole i'm really passionate about
the whole mixtape right right right yeah
so it's gotta be a way
i always i always do it i always give
them away
and decon just came to the table and
what they did was actually help me with
some of the videos
okay well you know it was going to be a
bit out of budget to shoot well here
like the tyler video that you guys did
trouble on my mind was crazy yeah you
know what i'm saying like you know some
records man
and people don't understand it like um
you know i'm really just a i'm a rapper
man right like i really rap and that's
what i can do i can i can tell you about
you know putting the line together but i
don't have all the visions for all the
visuals i just don't you know what i'm
saying and if it's left up to me every
time
it'll probably be just one dimensional
yeah yeah so
you know pairing up with decon like they
they uh they give me a way to you know
to to showcase
what i want to get across yeah um uh of
course you're with good music for sure
um
are you still coming out with your debut
i'm on black friday is that still gonna
no no no i'm not gonna put it out on
black friday but um what can you tell us
about the actual album is it i mean how
much of it is it is done i mean it's
it's it's not finished it's not finished
the actual album is not finished and i
don't have a title for you you don't do
not so i've been making records so we're
gonna be waiting a while for it no no
because i've been making records i mean
i gotta just don't know what's gonna be
i don't know what's gonna make the album
um
we've found a groove though yeah
definitely found a groove
and um
i can honestly say that uh with yay
executive producing this thing is gonna
be a masterpiece um lyrically no one
thing lyric driven 100 percent
street no for sure
street for sure that's what i was going
to ask you because i've been man i've
been a fan since you know sophomore year
in high school when lord willing came
out on
and all the mixtapes everything uh what
what is
i guess what's the difference between
uh you as a solo artist and and the work
with malice
well i think you know when you're in uh
when you're in a group there's certain
roles that you play i think malice
always played the the introspection the
good guy yeah the introspective the more
thought provoking and i was more of the
branch right right right more the brass
more um
metaphor ignorant metaphor yeah here
you're here and i and it's not that i
don't i don't think and it's not that i
don't um have a
introspective
you know perspective
but i think that was always left up the
malice because he was always good at it
right right so um i think you're gonna
get a lot more of that you know a lot
more of that a lot more of that um
when it comes to the debut album uh
kanye of course
executive producing it yeah production
wise is uh is neptune neptune's and
kanye gonna be on it yeah yeah yeah i'm
getting stuff for you [__] you did it
with your little twos it's sick listen
i'm still trying to get with khalil
again yo like one of those i think he's
a little stuck on producers
just blaze
not
no id maybe no i d better
i need that okay i need that for the
album yeah for the album
um
i've been doing a lot of begging
honestly i'm gonna let you all know you
got to do bacon
bags i beg for a good track oh yeah i'm
big man i ain't even gonna front there's
certain you know certain things man just
gotta have to have to happen and and i
need it man and
you know i need it you've collaborated
with with so many artists um yes who i
mean this is this is your first solo
album man yeah and a lot of people you
know when they drop that debut album
like nas or you know hellmatic you only
had a z on it what are you going to
what route are you going to take with
the feature processor is it going to be
just you are you going to
keep it in the fam
it's not going to be just me
and
if
you know i'm such a fan of hip-hop that
i can honestly see myself
collaborating with just all the people
that i'm liking like you know they will
like because sometimes you know that
that's a little bit of a process too
sometimes
sometimes you want to get with certain
people and they don't get the record
right right right
so a primo record would be crazy always
that's so classic
that'd be crazy um like like uh the
whole situation with you and your
brother i know i know malice has dropped
the book yes which is making a lot of
noise um is he done rapping or is is the
clips done for now or y'all
no we uh because we need to i i i love
you as a solo artist that would be it
there's got to be more clips out yeah
okay for sure there'll be another clips
out me and malice talk about it all the
time um
you know that's not ready yeah yeah he's
so ready he's you know right now he's
really doing his book and people don't
even understand that like
we were ready to go back in on another
clips album after the last one and he
was like nah go ahead because i'm about
to write this book and then he
physically writes the book which was
which is crazy ridiculous to me it was
absolutely crazy which was a stunt he
was just stunned he's just starting like
yeah i could write a book you know what
i'm saying i could write a book uh the
situation with consequence man um yeah i
know you've already kind of spoke on it
yeah um
i mean
i i don't know what's going on but how
do you i mean i i'm a hip-hop fan and
and how he called you out for stealing
the line or whatever i didn't get that
yeah you know what i'm saying i didn't
get it at all because nobody does to me
you're one of the nice like you're
you're in my top 10 of all time i think
and i don't understand it is what it is
like i like consequence i like his music
he's not a bad rapper you know what i'm
saying but what
where do you stand with that now is it
just kind of like
um
there it is all right so uh
album um no title yet no about eight
songs in yeah um who knows if i'm gonna
keep those yeah you know you never know
but we'll see you never know there it is
my g well hey man oh [__] my phone is
going off in the middle of the interview
and everything
hey i wanted to ask you one more thing
um about about your guys's first album
lord willing how often do y'all go but
do you go back and listen to lord
willing i listen to hell happen on fury
every day you listen to how i know
you're it's my favorite album okay okay
he'll have blueberry the best album one
of the best albums ever made i i i my
favorite album from y'all honestly was
so the casual drops i don't it was to me
it was the most it was the deepest album
yeah yeah you know it's a fight man but
he'll have no fury to me is just the
most
that's the evilest album i've ever been
a part of evil evil nasty there it is
ridiculous pusha t i appreciate it man
yo